Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute Papers
with Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
OpenAI's Gym was a selection of gaming environments
for reinforcement learning algorithms.
This is a class of techniques that are able
to learn and perform an optimal chain of actions
in an environment.
This environment could be playing video games,
navigating a drone around, or teaching digital
creatures to walk.
In this system, people could create new reinforcement
learning programs and decide whose AI is the
best.
Gym was a ton of fun, ... but have a look
this one!
How is this different from Gym?
This new software platform, Universe works
not only for reinforcement learning algorithms,
but for arbitrary programs.
Like a freestyle wrestling competition for
AI researchers!
The list of games include GTA V, Mirror's
Edge, Starcraft 2, Civilization 5, Minecraft,
Portal and a lot more this time around.
Super exciting!
You can download this framework right now
and proceed testing.
One can also perform different browser tasks,
such as booking a plane ticket and other endeavors
that require navigating around in a web browser
interface.
Given the current software architecture for
Universe, practically any task where automation
makes sense can be included in the future.
And, we don't need to make any intrusive changes
to the game itself, in fact, we don't even
have to have access to the source code.
This is huge, especially given that many of
these games are proprietary software, so to
make this happen, individual deals had taken
place between the game development companies
and OpenAI.
When the company was founded by Elon Musk
and Sam Altman, they have picked up so many
of the most talented AI researchers around
the globe.
And I am so happy to see that it really, really
shows.
There is an excellent blog post describing
the details of the system, make sure to have
a look!
Also, I reckon that our comments section is
the absolute best I've seen on YouTube.
Feel free to participate or start a discussion,
there are always plenty of amazing ideas in
the comments section.
Thanks for watching and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!